well let's talk now with gabe
DeBenedetti he's a national
correspondent for New York Magazine Gabe
good morning morning well the president
said closing the border would be quote a
profit-making operation how so and how
does this change things with our
relationships with a Latin America well
it's not exactly clear how he thinks
it's going to make too much of a profit
most economic analyses I've seen of this
suggest the opposite here a lot of folks
basically think that there's no way that
this is gonna make any money but he's
not really doing this to make money of
course and he's been pretty clear about
that this is a political move he's going
back to the campaign mode talking to his
base he knows that you know people
around him really like it when they can
talk about immigration when they can
talk about shutting the border and this
would be yet another return to basically
saying or cracking down on illegal
immigration rest of Latin America
obviously not very happy but a number of
members of his own party voted against
the emergency declaration how would they
feel about this do we think they're not
thrilled but of course it's very
difficult for a lot of them to break
from him we haven't seen a ton of them
stand up and say I'm going to vote
against this or I'm going to try and
stop him but I think you might see a
little bit more of that as folks on
Capitol Hill try and understand what
this is actually going to look like you
mentioned it's a political calculation
the president had his first major
political rally since the malla report
came out there was some colorful
language there was some schoolyard
taunts of his political opponents what
else came out of it that struck you yeah
well I think this is a return to the
politics of grievance for the president
you could have seen him say basically
you know the Russia stuff is behind us
now let's move on and talk about some
issues that matter to the American
people that's not exactly how he works
of course he went after Adam Schiff in
particular the Democratic chairman of
the House Intelligence Committee and
that was really what struck me the
ability to or his unwillingness to move
on and really double down in this rush a
question and turn this into again a
partisan fight does he want any risk you
think Gabe if the report comes out and
some details are not so flattering by
sort of trying to suggest we've moved on
here does he run a risk that this could
come back and bite him yeah absolutely I
think the reality here is that on
Capitol Hill at least this fight is far
from over Democrats have made very clear
they're still investigating they still
want to see the 4 molar report and they
want this to be a broad national
conversation the president has said
let's moved up let's move on from this
but of course
he hasn't moved on he's still talking
about it the presidents now pushing the
subject of health care Mitch McConnell
in the Senate
not so much yeah what do you see playing
out there well I've never seen House
Democrats so happy in the last year's
because they thought oh my goodness this
is one of our lowest moments here after
the beginning of the Moller report
starting to come out and all of a sudden
the president has said let's talk about
the one issue that Democrats keep
winning on so that's why you see Mitch
McConnell and the Senate more or less
saying you know we have to try and win
the Senate we're not gonna focus on this
this one's up to you in the White House
here so there's a pretty big divide in
the Republican Party but Democrats are
thrilled to be talking about it could
there be a pivot for from president
Trump people been talking about him
potentially pivoting toward a center at
some point if he's cleared now no
collusion and the principal conclusions
in the in the bar summary if then the
whole mullet report comes out and and it
looks good for the president could
heading into 2020 we see a more centrist
president Trump you think that's gonna
happen
could it happen yes do I think it's
gonna happen of course
now anything is possible anything is
possible but as you said we've been
talking about a pivot to the center for
the president for four or five years now
and he likes going off-script he talks
about going off-script and whenever
someone tries to hem him in he says
that's not how I do things I really felt
like if there was gonna be a pivot this
would be the moment but I guess it's not
coming yet keep waiting game thank you
very much thank you